bring in former secretary of state
former cia director mike pompeo mr
secretary thanks for the time
it's great to be with you brett thanks
for having me on tonight
you know ronald reagan obviously said
trust but verify what do you make of
vladimir putin's at least announcement
that some of the russian troops are
pulling back from that border
well that's hard to go wrong with that
reagan aphorism i might add distrust but
verify to i heard putin today speaking
acting as if he was the peacemaker when
he was in fact the person who brought
all this uh current uh kerfuffle on we
shouldn't credit him for now making a
statement says well maybe it's time for
me to negotiate and i'll pull some of my
troops back
the other thing we need to make sure to
keep in mind brad is that it's not
binary we talk about it invasion or not
in fact we saw the cyber attacks today
we'll see where they actually came from
but vladimir putin's been at war with
the west for an awfully long time in
ukraine in particular can't forget he
took one-fifth of that country just a
handful of years ago so we're always
caught up in just the moment we were
working so hard at this brett i met with
my counterpart uh many many times mr
narishkin at the svr met with vladimir
putin vladimir putin thanked me and
president trump for saving lives in
saint petersburg we always knew that you
needed to make sure and have good
conversations develop whatever level of
relationship you could work together if
you can save lives in a place like
russia you ought to do that but when you
came to the very defending america's
interest we were pretty clear we were
going to do that every single day
you know democrats on capitol hill
obviously see this differently some look
through partisan lenses others say that
the two administrations dealt with
things differently here is senator mark
warner
the administration's approach is frankly
significantly different from the
previous president in this country
who undermined the transnation
transatlantic alliance questioned the
very needs for its existence and took
every opportunity
to weaken the shared bonds that have
kept peace in europe since world war ii
your thoughts on that
it's unfortunate that you see a partisan
frankly unfounded comment like that i
promise you you had the nato secretary
general on just a little bit ago i know
general stoltenberg secretary general
stoltenberg very well he was thankful
for what president trump did for what
our administration did we flowed
resources to nato we made each country
stand up and prepare better to defend
itself secretary general stoltenberg is
much more capable and his force is more
capable today because of what the trump
administration did now i it's precisely
opposite when you coddle when you say
look this is no longer important we're
going to turn inward we're going to lead
from behind that was the wrong approach
it shouldn't be partisan we want a
strong united nato we want to make sure
that the things that matter to people in
nevada and across the united states of
america are stood up for and protecting
a democracy in ukraine is something we
ought to do for our own best interest
i'd had one more thought here brett i
heard president biden say that he's
worried about american energy prices
because of something that russia does
in fact american energy prices are high
today because of what president biden
has done he shut down the capacity for
america to produce its own affordable
energy
don't let any leader hide behind what
some other actor does america can have
affordable safe abundant energy from its
own internal resources we demonstrated
that in our four years
mr secretary you mentioned something
about president biden's speech today
what about the rest of that speech as
you look through it and kind of read
through the lines there as you look at a
map of the russian forces around ukraine
i mean it's it's ominous but should
americans be worried about russian
action against america cyber or
otherwise and and how did you read that
speech
yes it's it's true we do have interest
in ukraine i've heard some say that we
don't have any interest there i've heard
others say we have maximal interest
there it it's it's the case that we have
important interest that we should defend
them but
every situation is different this one's
certainly the case
russia does have the fact the impact
that president biden described they can
affect american lives a big chunk of
wheat flows through the sea of azab in
the black sea energy prices for sure he
can constrict and destabilize the market
he can he can mess around in the middle
east and present real risk to our friend
and ally israel vladimir putin has many
tools not the least of which is still a
thousand nuclear warheads had
we gave him at the very beginning of
this administration we gave him the
brand new extension of new start
asking for nothing when new start covers
almost all of our weapons and just a
fraction of the russian weapon systems
those are the kinds of mistakes that
lead someone like vladimir putin to
believe that he can uh that he could
push around the united states that's the
big mistake uh just last comment here
brett
uh people have asked would this have
happened under president trump i don't
think so i can tell you this it didn't
happen and the only thing that has
changed was who was leading the united
states of america
secretary mike pompeo we appreciate the
time
thank you brett have a good day sir hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else